das kann er nicht sein hahahahaha was
los was los was los was passiert was
passiert hier was ist los alter junge
leute und herzlich willkommen zu einer
weiteren folge hexel auf dem mirror
server shuffle und zander sind man auf
dem server und ich werde jetzt auch
drauf gehen wird jetzt hier noch weiter
die glasscheiben abbauen und danach mein
haus ein bisschen weiter fertigstellen
und danach einfach mal schauen ob ich
irgendwo eventuell links finden werde
der ist die kacke aluminium ist ja schon
mal cool dass die mir was geschenkt
haben aber dafür bräuchte auch dies
melden aber da ich diesmal tritt zurzeit
nicht benutzen kann wenn ich dann
einfach irgendwann jetzt also ich habe
ja jetzt aufgenommen bis also ich nehme
gerade am zwölften ersten auf das ist
relativ früh eigentlich für meine
verhältnisse weil die folgen sind vier
tagen glaubt anderen kommt in vier
die folge die jetzt gerät kommt am 16
am 16 kommt diese folge dementsprechend
ist es eigentlich relativ ruhig aufnehme
allerdings versuche ich dann irgendwann
nochmal mit cap aufzunehmen
dass der mir zeigt wie genau ich diese
scheiß redstone kacke da die irgendwer
da gebaut hatte ich glaube sogar dass
verkauf mich das irgendwie ausmache oder
wie ich diesmal wieder nutzen kann oder
so weil es ist relativ durch dass da
noch was drin ist und ich habe zwar
keinen bock mehr dass mary selber zu
bauen
wenn man diese in deutschland zu kommen
es glaube ich relativ schwer deswegen
mache ich mich jetzt erst mal auf die
suche nach aluminium dass ich die sachen
habe in dieser folge die ich so brauche
dafür
na ja alles gut so dieses haus werde ich
glaube ich einfach mal abbrennen
weiligmann mit den blöcken werden wir eh
nix in der stadt bauen und die ersten
ausgabe kommt bei mir ins haus von daher
kann ich ja wieder mal ein feuerzeug an
machen
na gut aber erstmal werde ich mein
anderes haustier hinten fertig bauen
sprinter doch du [ __ ] behielt er
noch ein glas so jetzt ist halt die
frage sondern also ich werde auf jeden
fall ein camouflage block bauen für die
türen hier das ist die tatsächlich
eingebaut
er hat kämpft das eigentlich die kef hat
es nicht gemacht hier kommt jetzt erst
mal so ein buch wie heißen die hand
nehme ich als ort ich wusste jetzt echt
cool wie denn diese blöcke heißen diese
kleineren blöcke meine ich jetzt die ich
so irgendwo dann mal anbringen kann
es darf an anna so dass uns auf jeden
fall nicht dabei da sind 60 linke sachen
o barry medley obstsalat buch habe ich
viele waffen ist auch tauschen lorscher
alter das ist geil ist kein crafting
rezept dabei
diese findet ihr dann nicht gibt es hier
gar nicht wie haben die denn hier gebaut
wir wissen dass hierfür blöcke was das
los los na ja gut ich möchte eigentlich
sagen so einen coolen eingangsbereich
irgendwie bauen besten ich brauche ich
noch mehr von von
von espresso
dementsprechend muss ja okay ich müsste
vielleicht ich möchte meine axt fleisch
so und zwar kommt das jetzt einfach mal
hier hin
hier kommt es da auf sondern könnte ich
ja theoretisch noch mal so als hinbauen
dann kann ich auch gleich wenn ich jetzt
schon bin da noch einen draufsetzen und
das hier weiß ich gar nicht was er
machen soll
eigentlich muss dann müssen also türen
aber eben diesen türen dorf ausfindig
so jetzt kommt hier noch sein
da muss ja denn ich weiß meine schaufel
und dich auch hier sollte ja sonst so
ein komischer eingangsbereich diese ist
die so langsam ist immer noch relativ
schnell aber ich hatte ja dich zack zack
zack zack zack zack zack das ja auch
schnell geht
hier kommen nämlich erzeuger es wird
dunkel so hier kommen parkraum abel hin
einfach so und jetzt kommt hier nämlich
der weg so rum
horst may ja ich geh einfach schlafen
manchmal so zack zack
dann packt als noch fackeln drauf die
ich aber gar nicht dabei deswegen gehe
ich eben kurz schlafen und dann ich
denke dass unser haus relativ schön wird
wenn ihr da ihr dürft ihr somit bestimmt
ich das machen soll ich meinte die
andere macht das ein eingangsbereichen
bla bla mache ich jetzt auch
also da die fackeln die ganze kriegs
café brauch erst mal gar nicht
fackeln ich bin im bordell modus ich bin
im büro modus
ap
das sieht alles im pathos wer das
aluminium
dafür geben wir geben uns gleich auf die
aluminium suche so und jetzt muss ich da
irgendwie weithin bauen wenn man so
machen weil sie das chaos
wir haben dann schon ein relativ großes
haus obwohl wenn er die essensausgabe
reinkommt und so ist es ja doch relativ
klein eigentlich keine ist es nicht aber
morgen wiesenboden aus marvel wäre auch
geil hier muss selbstverständlich holz
hin
damit hat mit frederic spohr
wie heißt denn dieses holz habe ich da
nicht noch irgendwie watt von irgendwo
da ist das nein das ist nichts bluesport
nein nein das ist nicht bloß wird es ist
das gerät points es ist die frage was
mache ich die türen und da gemeinden
hier der jobo standard so sollten
eigentlich
eigentlich wollte ich das allerdings
kacke bauern aber mein schoko kann er
ihr rausfliegen von daher werde ich das
glaube ich
es sollte werden wie soll ich könnte die
camouflage blogs da einfach so an die
wände setzen was ich da so durch kann
oder einfach oben drauf das wäre geil
obendrauf einen drauf er richtig geil
das will ich richtig feiern so dann
bräuchte nur noch eine tür dann gleich
rein dann mache ich ja die seiten
einfach was kann ich denn hier an die
saiten packen
einfach so fortsetzen hier
ich weiß nicht
das ergibt dass zweistöckig werden soll
unsere stadt ist so leer wir sind
einfach nur noch vier leute bei uns in
der stadt das ist so traurig ja gut ich
lass das ganze erst mal so wir können
das ja immer noch mal ein bisschen
verschönern ja alles wir geben uns nun
auf die suche nach so dass ich mir die
bausachen rein
wir begeben uns auf die suche nach
aluminium meine damen und herren es geht
los so die spiegel kommen natürlich mit
der elektrik stuff kommt dahin ich meine
höhle das einfach ein so und stieß ich
denn jetzt bakteriellen acht habe ich
orthogonal fehlt dann kann ich mir
wieder so einen disco blog machen den
frost brauch ich kann eigentlich gar
nicht so so ich brauche noch einen fall
so die spiegel mauch hatte ich habe doch
den staat laut spiegel drin
ja okay das gut dann
so die brote dient eigentlich auch erst
mal unnötig
ich brauche die person bisschen was zu
fressen ich habe aber glaube ich gar
nichts zu fressen diamant oder habe ich
da noch drin
ich kann es ehrlich gesagt nicht glauben
dass ich komplett ja kein links hat
aluminium
irgendwie glaube ich das nicht
das kann auch immer ich muss doch
irgendwann mal aluminium abgebaut haben
aluminium nein nein nein nein nein
mit aluminium nugget ich verstehe es
nicht
was kann ich machen nix mit aluminium
blabla ja gut ich wäre eigentlich
ausgerüstet sein polster freut auch
nicht ich wette ich vergesse nie wieder
irgendwas ich nehme sich jetzt aber mal
noch eine schaufel mit und spitzhacke
cloud boots
ich habe nur schwerter ich habe keine
nutzer teams irgendwie ich bin oft
gestellt wieso und penner alter was zu
abbauen angeht unseres darf ja gut ist
jetzt egal wird schon reichen irgendwie
ja ich nehme einfach noch zwei deckt rig
stars mit er kam noch ein
wo ist der mensch okubo und man das
hätte ich jetzt so gerne acht kommen die
fifa einfach das wär doch cool
wir sind schneller unterwegs hier die
sonne gar nicht heftig verzaubert
eigentlich geht kaputt wenn ich so laufe
einfach ich frag mich das echt wo ist
mein verdammtes chocobo habe ich das
denn hingestellt
es ist doch nicht das hier einfach oder
oder ist es dass sie ich nehme jetzt
einfach dass hier jetzt ist dass er
wieder so buggy mit dem mit dem dings
abwegig dass die welt dann einfach mal
so ein bisschen laden wir gehen jetzt
erst mal ein bisschen weiter weg wo
eventuell nicht so viele leute waren war
noch nicht viele leute hat karte soll
ich mal wieder an machen kommen wir hier
lang
wenn man so ein bisschen gucken werden
wir wollen noch ein tower mitnehmen
ach komm ich selbst auch ihnen die
schuhe aus es ist sehr langweilig denn
hier alles sei vielleicht ein paar
existenzen kamera mal nachschauen oder
auch mal noch ein auf dem turm
das ist ja cool soll dann fliegen wir
jetzt eben hoch
so meine sachen krallen dass wir auch
cool wenn hier oben einfachen dings drin
wäre zu aluminium oder so hallo kleine
spende da betrifft wieder nicht magic
ist es ganz gut in chan tim kacke golden
chariot ich schau mal was drunter noch
alles so ist hp halo nicht sowie
behinderten machte schließlich
gegenseitig ob er das neues deine
kollegen gehen jetzt auch nicht oder wie
soll ja bla bla bla bla bla bla aus der
kohle mag sich da hoch gut weil jetzt
ausziehen
ich brauche da hinten sieht cool aus
da ist eine hexe kahle sense nice
vielleicht können uns dann endlich auch
die triebe aber wieder finish macon die
stars ananas dass ein skelett mezcal die
trivial aber das ist diese arme kennt
ihr vielleicht noch von kannst als von
meinen ersten folgen die ich damals
einmal hat und dachte ich wäre überbau
damit die ist auch eigentlich relativ
gut die finde ich immer noch geil
damit kann man halt höher springen so
ein bisschen was aber nicht
ja keine ahnung wir suchen blöcke die
einfach so einer pump herum stehen die
man dann so abbauen kann so greven
blöcke mit symbol dran drauf keine
ahnung
ihr könnt auch einfach mal an so höhlen
gucken grabsteine von angst vor dem nur
gesehen dass da welche einen schuss
drauf gemacht haben sind directly tod
alter verräter mongolei angst vor
solchen leuten die so komisch sind vor
allem der hatte ja keinen kopf wenn das
der normale krieger gewesen wären okay
ein inventar es voll okay okay
fakt ist einfach mal acht das guck ich
hab schon wieder nämlich irgendwas
vergessen ich hab's gesagt ich war jetzt
irgendwas ich habe einen rucksack
vergessen hast meine facebook hat sich
dachte ich am fluss gefunden
ich habe viel mut gefunden so kommt auch
allen drei goldene äpfel auch cool
roth ja keine ahnung ich glaube das wird
sehr traurig diese reise ich denke wir
werden nicht so viel finden
das war ein bisschen ja keine ahnung ich
weiß ja gar nicht wo genau ich da
wirklich so nach suchen soll
ich brauche halt echt einfach blöcke die
irgendwo herumstehen wir karten wir
jetzt manager fast nie ich brauche
wirklich einfach travel blöcke und die
müssten irgendwo rum stehen und aber
aluminium sondern auch sehr sehr selten
seien
also wenn ich das schon höre dass das
sander 2 haben und so eine kiste
achental
statt um so hält der sonst nicht besser
so besser komme ich manchmal muss man
sie mache ich die staaten neues weg
möchten aber töten den pc auch keine
ahnung ich glaube mal seine kiste eben
diamanten bla bla bla bla
so geht's kollege aus den usa wo sind
wir hier
was ist das alter giftig dies passt so
komisch aus nee ist nicht giftig aber
das bringt doch so komisch meine night
vision geht weg online ist jetzt auf dem
golden shoe co
hey wie verrückt ist das denn was ist
das für ein bio hier rasches wasser
gefragt fast dass es die welt keine
ahnung wo wir sind und was das ist und
das bereitet mir mal so ein bisschen
angst wenn ich die sache nicht weiß
herbert haus kaputt der andere war noch
zu untergrund kann nicht sein wir müssen
jetzt mal diese blöde ich möchte jetzt
wieder an das ist mir ein bisschen zu
langweilig war es vielleicht ein
bisschen zu schnell auf offenem meer
und nichts ist hier hallo möglich setzt
die schule wieder aus wir brauchen
aluminium das ist das allerwichtigste
mittlerweile für mich im spiel weil ich
diese art kanister brauche für also für
mehr leben dies das anders warum man
nicht gleich wieder nach hause das ist
traurig habe ich mich einfach durch mit
den aluminiumdach man denkt mal so ganz
kurz so wenn man so dem boden sieht so
aber da geht's nach oben
wir können über ein thema reden und zwar
das bringt jetzt auch nicht wenn wir 2
17 minuten themen an ich bin unterm
teppich mit meinem stuhl ist nicht sogar
in den tower
wenn da aluminium drin ist dann schreibe
ich aber also das wäre geil goldenbogen
schön griffig schon ja ich komme ich das
jetzt einfach mal mit hier next etage
ganz viele skelette hier auf einmal im
staat
ich war hier immer wieder ein stockwerk
tiefer weil diese sind alle tot
diamanten bauland inga school das cool
netter war ziemlich jetzt auch damit ist
ganz gut so für so paradis dass keine
ahnung
es war irgendwas was ich mal mit network
watson watson schwarzen piste ok was
damit mal machen wollte habe ich weiß
mehr was es war
wieviel benzin wir nachher haben ich
baue gerade was ab lasst mich in ruhe
miniatur herz wenn auch ganz cool wenn
ihr die verlassen würde meine lieben
brüder
doch irgendwas gusto barocco
tschuldigung dass die schon mit schoko
verwechselt das kann ja nicht sein die
ohio h was los was los was los was
passiert was passiert hier was ist los
alter was was ist das ich mach nix o a
ich fliege jetzt einfach mal dass wir
nach oben wo das vivaz wo das was ist
das was ich das projekt immer eben also
ich musste egis connecten aber ich will
jetzt wissen ob das irgendwie nicht dass
ich in der nächsten folge lange tot bin
oder so online das wäre so scheiße wenn
ich jetzt sterbe wegen verdammten pakt
komm bitte bitte ich möchte man die
knochen weg und ziehe mir die schuhe aus
oh ja wir leben meine damen und herren
aber ich kann mich bewegen doch ich kann
mich bewegen aber nur langsam
nur so buggy oha
ich glaube wir müssen nämlich doch nach
hause fliegen
mit dem turbo und nicht mit ich weiß ist
das wort mainz schreibt mir einfach wohl
meinte wo ist also ich glaube wir müssen
mit dem turbo hier nach hause fliegen
weil wenn ich mich teleportieren dann
wird das schoko borja nicht mitkommen
also ich bin nicht sein sagen sondern
ich habe so eine wanderhure ich hab
immer ein anderes coburg gut er die
ausbeute war relativ geil wir haben
ziemlich viele geile sachen bekommen elf
magic essenzen 414 bodypainting nur 14
stück
warum baum lag das jetzt alles so hoch
dass es hier sind noch acht nicht sehr
viel mehr gut wir haben auf jeden fall
eine menge coole sachen bekommen
ich sagte ihr dass jetzt mal ehrlich
partie noch ein paar sachen rein die
dann noch rein können die das bla bla
bla bla bla bla bla ein paar coole sache
man echt dabei immer noch einen
richtwert mexiko distanz wir haben
allerdings kein aluminium gefunden
das ist ein bisschen traurig weil
deswegen sie mir echt losgegangen na gut
meine lieben freunde so ist das leben
schreibt mir weiterhin wie ich an
aluminium kommen kann ob ihr da
irgendwelche tipps taktiken etc und dann
wäre ich das nächste mal in da in diese
richtung laufen weil da unsere stadt ist
genau da genau da und hab mich sagen es
euch gefallen hat könnte ich da jetzt
noch 164 wieder in rom heute in den
kommentaren
wenn es euch gefallen hat könnt ihr
gerne einen daumen hoch da lassen wenn
euch auf sowas chillige gefällt